thank you to Dollar Shave Club for
sponsoring this video go to
dollarshaveclub.com /bi graphics and
you'll get your starter set for just $5
let's get into it
[Music]
pop quiz which general defeated Napoleon
if you grew up speak English chances are
you answered Wellington the Duke you
commanded British forces at the Battle
of Waterloo Wellington was indeed the
man who oversaw Emperor Napoleon's
bitter ends but while Waterloo may have
been the epilogue to the Napoleonic Wars
it wasn't the grand finale no that had
come over a year earlier when one
general managed to smash Napoleon's
Grand Army invade France capture Paris
and forced the petty corporal to
abdicate his throne and go into exile
the identity of that man
while that was Prince Carl Philip Vaughn
Schwarzenberg the former supreme
commander of the Allied forces
Schwarzenberg was the first man in
history to defeat Napoleon in the field
when his army won the Battle of Leipzig
in 1813 but Schwarzenberg wasn't merely
a good general just months before he'd
been a Grand Army Field Marshal fighting
alongside Napoleon in Russia it even
helps arrange the Emperor's marriage yet
when the time came he would be only too
happy to deliver his former comrade the
killer blow an epic tale of brotherhood
and betrayal this is the life of Prince
Schwarzenberg the man who defeated
Napoleon
at the moment Carl Philipp von
Schwarzenberg was born on April the 15th
1771 there was little in the air to
suggest history was on the cusp of
changing his family were old-school
aristocrats comfortably settled in the
kingdom of Bohemia or as that point
controlled by Europe's most powerful
Royals the hapsburgs rulers of both
Austria and the Holy Roman Empire the
Habsburgs were also super big fans of
the Schwarzenberg seriously they got on
like an imperial house on fire and it
seemed karl was destined for a stable
life in their stable Empire even though
karl underwent military training as a
young man no one really expected him to
do anything beyond fight the odd small
war for the glory of the emperor but had
coal been born with second sight he
might have picked a different career
over in western europe a time bomb was
ticking a gigantic time bomb of
resentments and anger that was destined
to explode with enough force to reshape
the continent
the name of that time bomb France and
went finally went off it would very
nearly destroy the stable Empire that
Karl called home not that anyone in the
Habsburg lands was paying attention to
France right now in 1788 war broke out
between Austria and the Ottoman Empire
in the Balkans just as
seventeen-year-old Carl von
Schwarzenberg was graduating from
Military Academy
this being the olden days Carl
immediately purchased a lefthand and
ship in the Imperial cavalry and rode
off to fight for the subject of the
video subtitles the general who defeated
Napoleon Karl's first experienced war
was a bit of a mixed bag on the one hand
he turned out to be a courageous leader
of men on the other hands he also turned
out to be a sickly weed who would spend
most of his adult life or laid up with
illness a year into the war Karl fell
badly sick and we mean badly he was
discharged and sent time to recuperate
Wade spent almost two years there
pestering people for news from the war
however air was the news from France
which would really decide his future on
July the 14th 1789 an angry Persian mob
stormed the Bastille lynching its
command
it was the first sign that something was
seriously wrong with the Holy Roman
Empire's Western neighbor the first spot
of rain felt before an apocalyptic storm
we can only see this with hindsight
though in 1789 the Habsburg subjects
were way too focused on the school that
was the Ostrow turkish water make
preparations for the oncoming hurricane
come 1791 Schwarzenberg had recovered
enough to return to active service at
first he was posted to the Latorre
dragoons but everyone knew had only got
the job due to his high birth and
basically ghosted him until he stormed
off in a sulk so it was a quick
promotion to squadron commander and then
assignment to a different regiments just
in time for the water ends that summer
the Osman War concluded with a technical
victory for Austria but so little to
show for it that they might as well of
stayed home for Karl this was likely a
disappointment here it was his first war
and it turned out to be one of those
small boring was that even your history
teacher forgets bar there was no need to
worry
another much much bigger war was just
around the corner known as the War of
the first coalition it would kickstart a
period of turmoil that wouldn't end for
another 23 years
if the last few years in the Habsburg
lands had been spent around with
pointless Wars the last few years in
France had been spent making history by
1792 the Revolution was well underway
the National Assembly had deposed the
king and war mongering radicals are in
the ascent it was on to this potential
powder kegs that the hapsburgs dropped a
flaming match the declaration of
pillnitz was supposed to blackmail
revolutionary France into behaving by
threatening war if they killed their
king or attacked their neighbors but
this massively backfired when the French
National Assembly was all like you know
what actually sounds like a great idea
France declared war on April the 20th
1792 beginning what would become known
as the War of the first coalition it was
also the beginning of Karl von
Schwarzenberg
stunning career as a squadron commander
for the Hapsburgs karl was perfectly
placed to get stuck right into this new
war he was there at the Battle of near
windin on March the 18th 1793 helping to
beat back the French from the Austrian
Netherlands modern-day Belgium it was
also there at the Battle of Licata on
April the 26th 1794 leading his
regiments on a near suicidal charge
right into the French lines that smashed
them to pieces
it was this latter battle that first
established Schwarzenberg name as a
soldier netting him the order of Maria
Theresa the Habsburg highest military
honor
however Schwarzenberg wasn't the only
one making a name for himself in this
war across the lines on the French side
a brilliant young commander from Corsica
was rising through the ranks pulling off
impossible victories wherever he went as
you've probably already guessed that
brilliant young Corsican x' name was
napoleon bonaparte and in just a handful
of years he would go from fighting for
france to ruling it the War of the first
coalition finally ended in October 1797
with the Habsburg humiliated but not yet
down as the name suggests peace did not
last within just a little over a year
the war of the second coalition had
broken out and just a forewarn you
there's gonna be seven of these
coalition wars across this video you
would really think that Europe would
have gotten the don't screw with France
message after just
but apparently not they needed seven
sadly for Schwarzenberg er to sit out
the first couple of years of coalition
war to war harder after falling deeply
ill again in March of 1799 it's
interesting to speculate where his
career might have gone without this
illness although he eventually became
Europe's Tom general Schwarzenberg spent
something like a collective decade
parked on the bench
due to his ill health maybe he got lucky
maybe he'd have been killed in battle
and vanished from history if it simply
kept fighting all these coalition Wars
or maybe hid now be remembered in the
same breath as Napoleon himself instead
of as a supporting character in the
Emperor's story
speaking of Napoleon it was the war of
the second coalition that saw him
finally explode onto the international
stage on November the 9th 1799 the
general overthrew the French directory
in a coup taking over as first console
it was the beginning of the Napoleonic
era an era that would transform the
entire world it was also the beginning
of Schwarzenberg
own journey to greatness
[Music]
[Applause]
despite his illness Schwarzenberg was
back in the fields before 1800 was out
the hapsburgs must have been pretty sure
that he was their ticket to victory
because they promoted him to division
general and assigned him to Archduke
Charles the younger brother of Holy
Roman Emperor Francis the seconds it was
a huge promotion for a man not yet 30
and shows the confidence that was
already being placed in Karl
but alas one man does not an army make
well unless his name is Napoleon
although she Wattenberg pulled off
miracles at the Battle of Hoenn Linden
turning what might have been a route
into an ordered retreat this was never a
war the Hapsburgs could win on February
the 9th 1801 francis ii signed a treaty
with France ending his involvement with
the war although France had essentially
beaten Austria and the Holy Roman Empire
the terms were still quite lenient
lenient and after maintain peace for a
few years in the wake of this honorable
defeat Schwarzenberg stepped back from
military duties to begin his second
major career is that of a diplomat his
first assignment was to travel to some
petersburg and represent austria at the
coronation of alexander the first but
this was just a minor detour in his life
history because well let's be honest the
whole of Schwarzenberg his existence
revolved around one thing and that was
war and his most significant war yet was
already gearing up on December the 2nd
1804 Napoleon had himself coronated
Emperor in Paris around this same time
Europe's other powers decided to finally
put a stop to this French nonsense once
and for all
the third coalition formed over the
winter of 1804 to 1806 Charles again
sent for Schwarzenberg appointing him
vice-president of the Habsburg war
Council however he then proceeded to
ignore all of Karl's advice which
included staff along the lines of don't
go to war and seriously just don't is
anyone even listening to me as someone
who knew warp Schwarzenberg knew the
Holy Roman Empire and Austria were too
weak to take on Napoleonic France yet he
couldn't stop the inevitable in mid 1805
Austria joins the War of the third
coalition it would be a disaster of
history-making proportions the first
thing seemed to be going well in battles
such as Gunzburg and Hassler
French forces
were handily defeated allowing the
Austrians to advance
unfortunately what they advanced into
was a trap by rights the Battle of Ulm
should be a synonym of Omni shambles
under the leadership of karl max the
austrians advanced on were promptly
encircled by Napoleon's forces and they
immediately surrendered over 25,000 men
were captured alongside 18 generals and
basically the whole Austrian High
Command the only reason we had the
qualifier basically is because
Schwarzenberg managed to escape when he
saw what was about to happen
Karl pulled together his cavalry
squadrons and smashed them through the
French lines and away to safety that is
even more remarkable when you realize
that Schwarzenberg had fallen ill again
and should have been laid up in bed
instead of escaping the French ill or
not those Schwarzenberg made it back to
Vienna where he desperately warned
everyone not to repeat not to engage
Napoleon's forces again if only they had
listened on December the 2nd 1805 the
Holy Roman Empire and Russia faced
Napoleon at the battle of Austerlitz
outside the city of Bruno there's a
French smash their opponents so
thoroughly that nothing could be
salvaged in the aftermath of its defeat
the holy roman empire an empire that had
stood for roughly a thousand years was
dismantled while the Hapsburgs were able
to consolidate some of their lands
including Schwarzenberg home kingdom of
bohemia into the austrian empire the
scale of defeat was still colossal the
holy roman empire ended on the 6th of
August 1806 when Schwarzenberg received
the news he was so ill he appeared to be
a death's door yeah the shock of the
Empire's fall didn't finish him off
instead he slowly began to rally
although it would take three whole years
before he could return to active service
but this time he wouldn't be fighting
against Napoleon he'll be working with
him and just before we continue with
today's video maybe you should consider
working with Dollar Shave Club Dollar
Shave Club covers all of your grooming
needs shower oral care deodorants and of
course most importantly
shaving now I don't shave my beard
that's pretty evident well actually I do
shave here and here and a little bit on
the neck but I do shave my head and
since I switch dollar shave club that
has become just a better experience
because of these high-quality blades now
Dollar Shave Club sent me their ultimate
shave starter set which is courses you
know the blades also this really weighty
executive handle and unless you really
fill these you don't get a good idea of
you know the heft of this thing it feels
really good and the weight really gives
you better control then there's also
these three things that come along with
it and you get these in the right order
of course there is the prep scrub that's
what you do first then there is the
shave butter which of course you put on
and then you shave with the shaved
butter and then afterwards what I do I
rinse my head off I guess your dress
rinse your face off your shaving your
face and then you put on this post
shaved view which is really great I like
this stuff because I get a little dry on
my head after a shave so this helps keep
it moisturized it's fantastic you don't
wash that off you just stick it on and
you're done
so visit dollarshaveclub.com /bi
graphics and yet the ultimate shave
starter set for only $5 and why not
round out your grooming routine by
adding any of their other high-quality
products after that the restock box
ships full-size products at the regular
price and let's go back to the video
[Music]
as Prussia Russia and France Dukes it
out Carl von Schwarzenberg spent his
time back on light duties as an Austrian
diplomat well that meant he was in st.
Petersburg when Matunuck decided that
Austria joining the war of the fifth
coalition would be a splendid idea
the future foreign minister of austria
matin air would soon become an arch
manipulator seriously we've done a video
all about him I'd definitely check that
video out for more but he wasn't quite
there yet so his brilliant plan of
getting Schwarzenberg to convince Russia
to join the fray collapsed when Tsar
Alexander said you know what I'm cool
guys thanks for the offer
gonna sit this one out the war of the
fifth coalition would turn out to be
even worse for Austria than the last one
Napoleon smashed their army occupied
Vienna and forced Austria to surrender a
ton of territory even though
Schwarzenberg managed to drag himself
back to the field for the Battle of
Wagner among the 5th and 6th of July
1809 air was still a humiliating defeat
in the aftermath Metternich recalibrated
his empire stance no longer would
Austria be fighting France it would now
be cozying up to it
there was a whiplash inducing reversal
for everyone involved within a month of
Napoleon imposing a humiliating treaty
on Austria Schwarzenberg was rocking up
in Paris as the new ambassador coal
presented his credentials to the Emperor
on November the 26th it was the first
time the two had ever met but Napoleon
seems to have responded to the soldier
within Schwarzenberg because they
immediately got on like old BFFs it
probably helps that Schwarzenberg was
there in part to help arrange Napoleon's
marriage to Archduchess Marie Louise
with Austria now beat Matunuck decided
to offer the eighteen-year-old
Archduchess as a sacrifice guarantee
Napoleon wouldn't just dismantle their
empire it was Schwarzenberg job to make
sure that the Union came together and he
delivered in the spring of 1810 Napoleon
and Marie Louise were married that
summer Schwarzenberg organized a huge
ball to celebrate it was a drunk happy
occasion with ambassador's princes and
queens all in attendance
unfortunately the end of the evening
would be anything but cheerful at some
points a candle set fire to a curtain
causing an inferno that's
wept through the packed Hall 19 guests
were killed in the fire among them
Schwartz invokes sister in another age
the tragedy might have been seen as an
omen a portent of Napoleon's future but
this was an enlightened era the disaster
was written off as bad luck nothing more
a year and a half later the Emperor
began drawing up plans for his grand
invasion of Russia when it came time to
assemble his grand Army's foreign
auxiliaries he offered Schwarzenberg the
chance of leading them the Austrian
accepted without even batting an eyelid
it's one of the oddities of history that
the man who defeated Napoleon spends the
preceding year as the Emperor's comrade
in arms on the 24th of June 1812 the
Grand Army marched into Russia it was
one of the biggest fighting forces ever
assembled an international army over
600,000 strong down on its southern
flank Schwarzenberg shattered the head
of an Austrian force of 30,000 intending
to keep an eye on things around Warsaw
as Napoleon headed east to give the
Russians hell but first the Emperor
would have to find some Russians to
actually fight you probably already know
the story of the Grand Army's invasion
of Russia out the Russians fell back
without fighting burning crops and
cities until even Moscow was in flames
how they let Napoleon take the dead
capital and then just sat back and
waited for winter to do its work it's
curious to imagine how this must have
appeared to Schwarzenberg stuck cooling
his heels on the very edges of the
action he witnessed a whole ton of
soldiers marched off across the Berezina
River in summer confidence a victory
just a few months later he got to watch
as that Army's frozen bedraggled
remnants tried to Scrabble back to
safety the Russian army snapping at
their heels it was a hideous reversal of
fortune one only made possible by
temperatures so low that Napoleon's
troops had died in droves but
Schwarzenberg didn't gloat over his
former enemies comeuppance instead he
sprang into action
it was his Austrian auxiliaries who
formed the rear guard for the retreating
Grand Army keeping the advancing
Russians at bay allowing Napoleon to
regroup
it was a courageous stand but also dare
we said it was a bit of a stupid one for
the first time ever napoleon was
losing wasn't this the exact right time
for the Austrians to turn on the French
but then that was Carl Philipp von
Schwarzenberg he was a soldier not a
leader
if it was his duty as a soldier to fight
alongside France then by God hit fight
alongside her until he drew his final
breath for saving his retreat Napoleon
promoted Schwarzenberg to Field Marshal
a huge honor for a foreigner in the
Empress forces yet Schwarzenberg would
soon no longer be a part of the French
war machine with Napoleon's Russian
venture blowing up in his face meta knew
who is back in Austria being all like
hey guys we don't have to worry about
their guy anymore
great yes as Austria shifted to an
officially neutral position
Schwarzenegger led his soldiers south
away from the action back onto Austrian
territory his men say if he then
hightailed it back to Paris to try and
broker peace by now Napoleon was back in
the French capital even as his army
continued to suffer in Central Europe
Schwarzenberg begged his former comrade
begged him to do a deal maybe he was
just following Matan ex orders or maybe
Col really didn't want to see the French
Empire the place it now lived for years
totally collapse
either way Napoleon rebuffed him Emperor
still certain he could win this war
at last Schwarzenberg gave up shortly
after in August 1813 meta Nick brought
Austria into the newly formed sixth
coalition alongside Russia Prussia and
Belgium it was decided this huge Allied
Force needed a supreme commander someone
who could head its vast operations
across Europe someone even Napoleon
might respect you can almost imagine
Matunuck giving a smirk glancing at
Schwarzenberg and saying I've got just
the guy
[Music]
although she wattenberg technically
became supreme commander of the Allies
that summer in reality he wasn't as
supreme as he may have liked for one
thing every nation fighting the war had
wildly different goals and different
ideas of how to achieve them for another
call zone Emperor + Tsar Alexander and
precious King were also on the war
council and you better believe they
expected Carl to defer to them this
would lead to disaster at Dresden in
August of 1813 the war council decided
to advance on the city despite
Schwarzenberg basically saying dudes
it's definitely a trap but the war axe
refused to listen so the Allies advanced
Napoleon sprang his trap and the sixth
coalition was nearly destroyed it was
only Napoleon's own screw-ups that meant
the war didn't just finish there with a
French victory but Schwarzenberg was in
charge of general strategy and after The
Dresden debacle people started to listen
shorten Berg's plan was simple go slow
don't split our forces pick off
Napoleon's field marshals one by one and
for God's sake don't go prancing into
any more bloody traps in effect it
became a war of attrition with
Schwarzenberg huge army grinding slowly
on denying napoleon the epic battles had
been expecting until the grand army no
longer held the advantage finally in
mid-october Schwarzenberg was ready to
meet his former comrade on the field the
Battle of Leipzig also known as the
Battle of Nations was the largest single
engagement of monopoly onic Wars likely
the largest European battle prior to
World War one across four days I have a
half a million men fought to decide the
fate of Europe it was a titanic punch up
the Avengers end game to all these
coalition war sequels and at the end of
it the Allies stood victorious it was a
close thing on the first day Napoleon
nearly broke Rosenberg's Royal Army of
Bohemia before reinforcements could
arrive but the tired soon turns the
turning point was Schwarzenberg
personally leading a suicide or
counter-offensive cavalry charge that
drove Napoleon's troops back breaking as
advantage
it was the same ballsy move had pulled
way back during the war of the first
coalition a war that now must have
seemed like a distant memory and once
again it worked by October the 18th the
battle was over there had been a hundred
and twenty seven thousand casualties
that the Allies had done it for the
first time ever Napoleon had been
defeated in the field not by Russian
weather but by another general
Carl Philipp von Schwarzenberg had just
made history in the aftermath
Schwarzenberg pushed for an invasion of
France only to be rebuffed by nationair
who wanted to give the whole peace thing
another try but Napoleon's ego wouldn't
allow it
so On January the 1st 1814 Schwarzenberg
divided the Allied army in two and
marched half of it into southern France
the French campaign is today a great
what if the Bonaparte ists Napoleon
fought so well and won so many battles
that you almost want to declare him the
moral victor had he been up against a
slightly weaker opponents the war could
have ended very differently but
Schwarzenberg wasn't weak he held his
nerve as his forces inexorably moved
across France ignored the cries to press
his advantage and go storming ahead and
traps it was only when Napoleon had
ceased to cut the Allied lines of
communication that Schwarzenberg rolled
everything on the biggest gamble of his
career instead of pursuing his enemy he
raced north for Paris on March the 31st
1814 coalition troops entered the French
capital realizing his mistake Napoleon
tried to double back and lead the city's
defenses but it was too late Schwartz
invoked the city two days later on April
the second the French Senate deposed
Napoleon four days after that and the
Emperor abdicated ending his reign of
course this wasn't the end of Napoleon
in February 1815 the Emperor escaped his
island's prison and returned to France
kicking off a period known as the
hundred days it was this period that
ended with Waterloo with Wellington
defeating Napoleon for the final time
but by then carve on Schwarzenberg part
in this story was already over it ended
with him marching into Paris that day
triumphant the first man to have ever
bested Napoleon yet his triumph it
didn't last long in October of 1820
Schwarzenberg was back at Leipzig
revisiting the very site of the battle
at 14 seven years earlier while
surveying the battlefield the former
general suffered
a catastrophic stroke he died just days
later he wasn't yet even 50 when the
news broke Austria declared three days
of mourning the Russian Tsar said Europe
has lost a hero and I a friend one that
I shall miss as long as I live for
everyone alive in 1820 it was clear that
a legend had just died a Titan passed on
yet today some 200 years later who still
remembers Carl Philipp von Schwarzenberg
while Napoleon Wellington and even
Matunuck are still famous Schwarzenberg
has slipped through the cracks of
history disappearing into the footnotes
partly that's because of the hundred
days if your major claim to fame is
beating Napoleon it kind of puts a
damper on things if Napoleon then
returns yet the hundred days was just a
sad tribute act while Wellington was
undoubtedly talented his victory was
only so final because Schwarzenberg had
already laid the groundwork it already
showed the French their emperor's feet
were made of clay in learning about
history it's all too tempting to only
focus on the headline acts to only read
about the people whose names still
resonate now but the story of Prince
trottenberg shows that sometimes it's
the most fascinating characters who get
forgotten the most talented men who slip
into obscurity we will remember
Wellington today but we should also take
care to remember Karl von Schwarzenberg
the general who defeated Napoleon so I
really hope you found their video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below also support
this show by supporting our fantastic
sponsor Dollar Shave Club and I'll see
you next time
you